everyone thank you for having me so
today I'd like to reexamine some
assumptions about how open-source gets
built how we think open source gets
built and what is and isn't working
I'll be honest I wrote this talk for me
as much as I read it for you I've been
researching open source communities for
a couple of years now and I came to this
promise an outsider I'm not an open
source developer I'm just someone who's
interested in learning how open source
gets funded and supported and it was
good about that early on was that it
kept my mind open to possibilities
because I didn't have a background at
open source and I couldn't look to how
things have always been try answers but
a couple years in a year of which has
been spent deep in the weeds I get hub I
could feel a bit of resignation set in I
feel myself giving automatic answers to
things instead of questioning their
underlying assumptions and so I was
excited right this talk because I want
to reach challenged my thinking around
what open-source can be and excited to
explore that with you together today so
to start off and describe some of the
tensions that we're seeing in open
source
today I'll start with an experience that
you might be familiar with if you've
ever tried to make an open-source
contribution so let's say you're using
the library and you rent an error you go
into the repo you search through open
issues and it's already been reported
but then you realize oh I actually know
how to fix this
you open a PR you submit your requested
changes and you're excited because you
made a difference to this project then
he waits and you wait and you wait and
they kind of forget about it but one day
you're cleaning out your notifications
and you're kind of like huh whatever
happened to that PR you check it out
it's still open
nobody's ever responded except some
other person who's also asking what's
the hold up here then you wait a little
longer and more people pile on asking
what's taking so long but still you
don't get a response from the project
itself
you're like fine that's cool and all I
didn't need that contribution but also
what the heck isn't as open source both
these projects want contributions
and so it's possible they just didn't
like your contribution or maybe the
project just isn't actively being
developed anymore but another thing that
might be happening is this may be your
contribution got lost in a sea of
hundreds of unanswered issues and pull
requests that are piling onto materials
in box and in turn their guilty
conscience
may be and so open-source maintainer
czar fighting this information battle
they start with a project it's fun at
first and then the notification start
piling up so they start responding
faster and then that leads to even more
notifications there's an odd
productivity paradox that applies here
which you might have experienced with
your email you're applied to ten emails
you get fifteen back because efficiency
breeds more work you start getting
trapped in the cycle of notifications
and now somehow you found that the
better you do the worse your life gets
so what's going on here why am i Tina is
feeling overwhelmed and why is this a
new or interesting problem well part of
the problem is that more people are
using and participating in open source
than ever before so in 2001 when open
source in its current form first came
onto the scene you're dealing with the
total population of about 200,000 people
if we already use SourceForge as an
imperfect proxy and today it's more like
20 million people if we already use
github as an imperfect Pressy and so not
only are there more people but the
definition of a popular project has
changed with popular projects seeing way
more downloads than ever before so in
1998 a popular project like netscape
browser saw 200,000 downloads in two
weeks and today a popular NPM package
like lodash sees 21 million downloads in
two weeks recognizing of course that a
netscape browser and an NPM package are
not exactly apples to apples but numbers
around downloads and usage are really
hard to find and I'll talk more about
that later but either way projects are
seeing this exponential growth in use
but on the production side it turns out
there's been little to no increase in
the number of people maintaining these
projects
so you fast-forward 2017 and two-thirds
of popular projects on github still only
have one or two maintainer x' and to
some extent a software project can
absorb that kind of growth if those
users never enact with the project and
they just kind of took their software
and they quietly ran off into the sunset
everything might actually be okay but if
you've ever spent some time browsing
open issues on a projects you know
that's not the case
part of what's compounding the problem
right now is that it's not just random
hobby developers who are using these
projects but big serious companies -
most companies now say that they use
open source to run their business and as
you can see that number is doubled in
just the past five years or so and that
number comes from 2015 and in a survey
that we ran at github this year we found
that 94% of respondents say they use
open source at least sometimes in their
professional work today I've got not
just a random developer but a fortune
500 company that's using your project
and production demanding you to fix
things example of how this goes wrong is
the recent Equifax security breach which
they blamed on a vulnerability and
Apache struts an open source project
that they rely on which for the record
Equifax had failed to patch some time
but that kind of headline or the
potential for that kind of headline that
can cause a lot of mental burden Fuhrman
teeners so in fact today something this
with an unprecedent number of users
flooding these open source projects with
little to no increase in material
support as a result containers are
feeling like victims of their own
success
so before I dive into this I just not
take a step back and talk about what an
open-source maintainer is since I'm
gonna keep using the term and we're all
probably coming in here with different
ideas and definitions so for the
purposes of this talk I'm defining
maintainer x' as the people responsible
for an open source projects who are
having to do something besides writing
code so if you're reviewing other
people's contributions answering issues
anything like that that would make you a
maintainer and the maintainer role is
really important in open source projects
even if there aren't a lot of them
illustrate this concept I'm gonna borrow
a comp and I
from conservation biology called
keystone species so in conservation
biology a keystone species has a
disproportionately large effect on its
environment relative to its size they're
named after the keystone in the middle
of an arch which bears the least amount
of weight but if you removed it the arch
would still collapse so for example if
you imagine a forests their might but
not be that many wolves and absolute
numbers but if those wolves went away
the deer population would go unchecked
and if you had too many deer that would
affect the plant life and so on so those
are keystone species and maintainers are
like that a project needs maintainer x'
to do things like review and merge PRS
answer issues and keep the vision of the
project together both users and
contributors need things from in teeners
project might have hundreds of
contributors but if you remove the
maintainer x' even if there's just a
couple of them you put the whole project
in jeopardy
that's why maintainer x' are important
without them you've got unanswered
issues on merge PRS and dead or stagnant
projects so we're placing a lot of
demand on maintainer x' these days and
the short term response has been a bunch
of these coping strategies stuff like
limiting your time on open source
getting better at saying no adding
friction like issue or PR templates
right now we're calling these best
practices but they're basically coping
strategies and they're kind of defensive
tactics and if all else fails
maintainers aren't physically handcuffed
to their projects either open-source
software is provided as is so they're
under no obligation really need to
maintain anything at all part of the
coping strategy is also just making it
easier for maintainer x' to hand off
their projects and walk away if the work
gets to be too much so all that is fine
and good I could spend the rest of this
talk just breaking down those strategies
and that in itself is an important area
of work but perhaps a certain thought
has occurred to you which is wait a
second
isn't this open-source sure we can talk
about helping maintainer x' learn how to
cope but isn't part of the work also
just getting more people to pitch in
to which I would say yes the production
model that we've all been told to
believe is that open-source is all about
contributing back but as we've just
learned most projects curiously only
have one or two maintainer x' so the
interesting question to consider is
given what we believe about how
open-source works why aren't there more
maintainer
why hasn't maintenance killed beyond
these one or two people isn't the system
supposed to just magically work itself
out so to answer that question we have
to briefly revisit where these
assumptions came from in the first place
why do we actually believe that users
will become contributors and
contributors will become maintainer x'
so somewhere between 2001 where Steve
Ballmer called Linux a cancer and 2016
where he changes in mind we could
probably say that open source one early
two-thousands put open source in the map
right after the first dot-com bubble and
then somewhere in the mid 2000s there's
this layer of innovation from git and
github and Stack Overflow and open
source actually started to standardize
into a set of norms that we see today
and today we see Ballmer saying he dot
only loves open-source now but Microsoft
making headlines for its open source
participation and hiring so if 2001 did
2016 is kind of this time period we're
talking about the world has changed
quite a bit in the early 2000s and the
battle being fought was between closed
and open source that battle was
epitomized by Erich Raymond's essay the
cathedral and the bazaar which was
published to a wider audience in 1999 in
his essay Eric Raymond rejected the
notion of cathedral style software
development meaning not just closed
source software but even open source
software being built by just a few
people instead he proposed the bazaar is
utopian notion of software built in the
open those better and more secure
because being reviewed by hundreds of
people not just one or two the cathedral
bazaar was the right argument for its
time the vision of the bazaar helps sell
people on the benefits of using opens
software but today is more like The
Hangover after-party where we have to
come to terms with what we've done the
challenges we face today
weren't part of the earlier narrative of
open source because it was written in a
very different time most of the similar
research about how open source gets
produced was written in the early 2000s
and that became everything we operate
from today academics held open source is
this incredible model where people were
building software for fun and not for
profit it's not surprising that these
researchers were willing to overlook
basic economic theory and from the books
and the papers I've read through this
seems partly tied at least to the hacker
mythology that was driven by Steven Levy
in the 1980s which made researchers less
likely to question the motivations of
people that just seemed kind of
different from them in every other way
whatever the case these days we're
dealing with a completely different
universe today github adds more new
projects per month than SourceForge
added during its entire lifetime back
then a wildly successful project would
see a hundred thousand downloads not 10
million downloads we had never put
projects with stress test of scalability
people had no idea what was gonna happen
when we got to this point and turns out
maintenance doesn't actually grow with
use you fast forward a few years an open
source kind of ended up looking like
this there is no bazaar there's just a
couple of people struggling to manage a
bizarre sized workload 2014 analysis by
boku found that 93% of NPA packages had
one maintainer and there is no
relationship between how many people
depend on a package versus how many
event a nur's it has so the big question
for today is it's not how do we get more
people to use open source because open
sources are ready the cultural default
the new question is how do we scale the
production model to meet this level of
demand there's a lot at stake here to
bring back to keystone species I kind of
see maintainer x' as the polar bears of
open source they're floating in this
vast ocean of unanswered issues and
unmerged pull requests on this sad
little chunk of ice
and that ice is shrinking everyday the
scary part is that these problems are
only going to get worse for a couple of
reasons firstly they're way more
software developers today than they were
in 2001 many of whom are new to this
work well that's probably a good thing
long term in the short to medium term
not only does it create more user demand
but new developers are more likely to
have support questions not feel
comfortable contributing back or
struggle with workflow when they do try
to contribute this experience for
example puts a lot of strain on
maintainer x' but even if we overcome
those challenges which I think are
surmountable and the size and the scope
of off of open source projects
themselves are changing software is
fragmenting we increasingly see more
small or medium issue projects with one
maintainer working across many of them
each project doesn't necessarily have
its own community anymore that's a
fundamentally different spread from this
big ecosystem with a robust contributor
community like Linux has those big
ecosystems will always exists today's
version might be something like node the
kind of project that creates
opportunities for more projects to
exists and in those situations yes
maximizing contributions can work pretty
well in terms of scaling to demand but
while those projects capture our hearts
as examples of the bizarre inaction it
turns out that they are actually the
exception there's a 2015 analysis of
most popular projects on github across
languages where they found that big
projects with over a thousand
contributors so stuff like Django or
rails or Linux made up less than 3% of
the popular projects they reviewed on
the other end they had twice as many
examples so it's still only 6% but twice
as many that had less than 10
contributors ever most popular projects
were somewhere in the 10 to 250
contributor range at the time the point
being that these really big bazaars
don't represent the normal experience of
a popular project even if they are the
most mythologically captivating again
these are all time contributions so when
the researchers dig deeper they found
that half of the
total contributors these projects only
contribute once and never again and if
you want to guess what percent of
commits that accounts for it's less than
2%
so yeah this very long tail of very
small contributions you may have
hundreds of total contributors but the
bulk of daily work is still being
carried by just a few people and so it's
these medium is project Slyke a library
or module that suffer the biggest
existential threat today it may be part
of a larger ecosystem but they're not
directly associated with it some of them
aren't cool enough for anyone to want to
contribute to or they may be too complex
to contribute to even if people need to
keep using and benefiting from them and
so if fragmentation is a software
pattern that we're getting used to then
we need to rethink the production model
behind it some of that's resolved will
and how projects themselves are set up
so automated testing and releases shared
configuration and tooling across
projects but part of it is reorienting
how we think about the makeup of our
projects contributors the vast majority
of one-time contributors didn't come
there to join a community we know this
because researchers have asked them they
were there to fix a problem once and
move on and in fact that long tail of
people does make non-trivial
contributions it's good that they're
there and when they're not burdensome to
manage maintainer is universally seem to
like them and yes some of those
contributors might get excited about the
project and they might want to stick
around and those are the stories that we
tend to hear about I think there always
be the steady churn of people who can
choose who contribute once and never
again I mean what I'd like to propose is
that maybe it's okay that they don't
stick around our expectations of what
these contributors are or what they
should be is not rooted in reality most
of the rhetoric around contributor
communities works really well for big
projects
it just doesn't reflect the experience
of smaller ones today open-source is
doing increasingly good job of catering
to first-time contributions this kind of
work revolves around making your project
welcoming writing clear documentation
setting up tests being responsive these
things do help attract new contributors
not to mention just making it a positive
and pleasant experience for everyone but
ask a maintainer how well those
first-time contributions are translating
into repeat contributors and they'll
sort of further brow and Quitely news
that um well it's not getting those
first contributions in a problem but
turning a first-time contributor into a
second time contributor over and over
again I hear Medina's wrestle with this
feeling of guilt they might personally
spend countless hours helping hundred
people make their first contribution in
hopes that one of them will stick around
sometimes none of them do
this is hugely emotionally taxing it
also comes to the expense of other
valuable project work many maintainer as
I've spoken to you have found that the
way they actually get people to stick
around is through building relationships
not simply pushing more people through
this churn what if we're just telling
overburden maintainer is to optimize for
a solution that doesn't actually lead to
more help and what does it cost
maintainer is to pursue a strategy that
doesn't work I worry that the rhetoric
of the bazaar makes it hard to talk
openly about these failures at some
point when we're not seeing the results
we want we might want to try a different
tactic casual contributions are a great
way to build a wide volunteer base and
encourage community engagement which is
good for the long-term growth of a
project this is similar to employer
contribution matching programs or people
who raise money to run a charity
marathon or a bunch of co-workers
getting together to volunteer to soup
kitchen it's less about the money and
it's more about community engagement but
who pays the people that run the soup
kitchen who pays the staff that
organizes the marathon these are just
two different sustainability problems
and we shouldn't conflate one for the
other contributors will always form the
heart of a projects community but for
your typical medium-sized projects
they're simply not a path to reducing
overhead we still need to figure out how
to support maintenance work I want to
challenge the expectation that most
volunteers are just maintainer is
waiting to happen I went to Shawn's the
idea that the contribution funnel is
just broken and if we somehow manage to
fix it all the mentee nur's problems
would just go away
and to some extent me until we know this
you probably experienced some version of
this problem at work also known as too
many cooks in the kitchen adding lots of
new people to a project can slow down a
project even more due to ramp up time
for new contributors additional
coordination costs and the limited
divisibility of some tasks it's not
always easy to carve off perfect
first-time contributor issues and Soma
teeners are making the trade-off right
now between investing and new
contributors who will probably turn off
versus moving the project forward in
other ways eirick Greymon explicitly
challenged brooks law and the cathedral
the bazaar many points of stories like
linux to disprove it but again because
we know that these ecosystems aren't
representative of most popular projects
today i still think there's some truth
here if you're not yet convinced I would
ask this what does it cost us
everybody in this room as users and
beneficiaries of the software to pursue
the wrong strategy what could the world
look like if we weren't expecting
maintainer x' to burn out and step down
if you weren't asking them to choose
between writing code and onboarding new
contributors if they had the resources
to be able to do both this is a world I
want to explore it's natural for us to
prioritize solutions that are right in
front of us because those are the areas
where we feel we have the most control
it's a lot easier than imagining entire
paradigm shifts but if we could look
ahead beyond solving for the immediate
short-term burden and design for a
future that's maybe three to five years
away you might find that we can create
something really beautiful as an example
this it turns out that one of the
hottest buzzword spaces right now is
suffering a similar maintenance problem
Fred Arizona co-founder coinbase
estimated that major improvements to
aetherium could translate to roughly 3
billion dollars in value by making the
protocol easier to work with when we
don't empowerment a nurse to do this
kind of work everybody including the
users misses out this is quote from Jeff
Dahmer about her of cloud era that says
the best minds of my generation are
thinking about how to make people click
ads this Court has really stuck with me
over the years and sometimes when I
think about the information cost that
all of us
experience with work I think about how
the best minds of our generation are
being spent checking email check
notifications being responsive to other
people's needs instead of proactively
creating new things that's a problem
that I think we can all relate to and by
giving open-source developers the
resources to be proactive and not just
reactive we can unlock a whole new world
of creation so let's entertain the
thought that maybe sustainability isn't
about getting more people to contribute
but empowering maintainer is themselves
how do we make maintainer ship a viable
path of work to answer that I'm gonna
wrap up this talk with a couple of ideas
which I noticed conveniently all start
with an I so I'm gonna call them three
eyes indirect independence and
infrastructure so the first one's it
directs something we can all be working
towards today is encouraging companies
to allow employees to work on open
source during the day
sometimes open source can be a hobby but
it shouldn't have to be so if you work
at a company with the resources to hire
open-source developers or if their
projects employees use that they could
be contributing back to and as we know
that's true for 94% of you I would
encourage you to advocate for that
internally as things stand today carving
off work time is probably the most
viable approach as an example of how
this has worked Babel as a JavaScript
compiler that is completely community
built and supported Henry zu is one of
babbles men teeners and he was spending
all of his free time and his weekends on
that work so he asked his employer
Behance for a dedicated work time now he
spends 50 percent of his time at work on
Babel which is a huge contribution
towards Babel sustainability if you're
just in doing something similar I'll
point to the program that my colleague
put together open-source Friday to
encourage employees to regularly
contribute to open source as well as
provide resources for you to make the
case to your employer the second still
viable today but a bit harder to
implement strategy is to raise money
independently for open source work there
are two paths that are frequently
discussed here first is starting actual
business around the projects and their
last strategies I make
charge for that's usually either
services paying for extra features or
paying for a permissive commercially
friendly license monetizing ABBA service
is still hard to do
not to mention risky when it comes to
managing community tress there aren't a
lot of products have done it
successfully and I don't think it works
every projects but it's one more option
to consider the other way to think about
raising money is through sponsorships
some projects have done this really well
and I think there are a few different
parameters here to consider you can do a
one-time raise like your Kickstarter
make you do an ongoing rains like your
patreon or open collective there's also
this question of whether you're raising
money for projects like webpack does or
for an individual maintainer x' work
like avenue does for you for view in any
case getting sponsors requires a bit of
canadian chaps and again success in this
realm really depends on the individual
projects and the people that use it I
think there will be a lot of opportunity
for intermediary platforms to help make
this work easier so helping creators
raise impressive sponsorships connect
them to sponsors or start businesses I
personally probably hear about a new
initiative every week now and that
wasn't true two years ago so while it's
still early I'm excited to see where
this all goes if you're interested
learning more about this topic I put
together a list of all the ways I
personally know that people get paid for
open-source work with examples and case
studies of each and it lives in that
repo and I encourage you to check it out
so finally I'm just assuming like way
out on the problem I think the long term
solution here is to start treating open
source like digital infrastructure what
does that mean it means not just
thinking on a situational per project or
a permit teener basis but coming up with
a shared understanding and norms around
how the open source software we all rely
on gets produced right now they're a
bunch of these one-off get lucky success
stories but if you can acknowledge that
everyone relies on open source now and
it's this hugely impactful public good
we should be able to attract and retain
talented people to work on it instead of
expecting that it's a hobby or it's
something that happens outside of your
day job I
if you think that's unrealistic you
might be interested to learn that
another form of public service
today's nonprofit sector didn't really
exist until after the Industrial
Revolution
the people who made a lot of money from
that time like the Carnegie's and the
Rockefellers use their philanthropy to
cap to capitalize a whole new sector as
a bit of a Mia Coppola to society so you
can measure there's a similar corollary
here of companies that have made
billions of dollars by using shared
open-source infrastructure who might now
feel compelled to figure out how to
support it long term how do we get there
this space is still really new so your
guess is as good as mine but I will
leave you with a few ideas inspired by
observations I've made about the history
of physical infrastructure like roads
and bridges so if we take the national
highway system as an example and how it
came about in the u.s. in the UK roads
were being built and maintained by local
volunteers and in local governments for
decades as that meant you had these
really poorly interconnected roads of
varying quality and it was hard to get
from point A to point B in any
centralized fashion what finally got
things to change in both cases was
having this story of risk and a story of
opportunity the risk story is one that
many of you might be familiar with
around military defense and preparedness
as well as avoiding local government
corruption similarly we have this
emerging narrative right now around
open-source sustainability that's all
about these risks so you have like
burned-out maintainer 's unmaintained
projects major security risks funnily
enough there is even a similar story
about this with roads where civil
engineers were being burned out by
having to fight through local politics
and so it's good that we have the story
about risk but I think it's just as
important to have a story about
opportunity when it comes to physical
infrastructure the story of opportunity
is often forgotten and that's about how
we needed better roads in an
increasingly interconnected world better
roads came as a result of a rise in land
travel and again after cars reached a
consumer market people finally fix the
roads because they were excited about
trade and commerce and they needed
better tools to get around I think we
have a similar story to tell about
digital infrastructure
why do these open source projects matter
it matters because we want to build good
software and why do we want to build
good software because software has
created enormous social and economic
value and it helped society do more
things but to get there we need reliable
tools to build with and that's why
sustaining open source matters our
digital infrastructure doesn't look like
physical infrastructure as in how it
gets built open-source is very global
and it's also decentralized which is a
good thing we want open source to be
community built you wouldn't want one
nation state or one large company
dictating how it should be built and
what it looks like but that also means
there's no obvious entity that can take
responsibility for its long term growth
it also means open sources value is
really hard to quantify because that
value is derived primarily from closed
source dependencies and we actually
don't know who uses these projects
unless companies voluntarily disclose it
there's a bit of insanity that comes
with that
it's a maintainer project that you know
is being widely used by major companies
or governments but you don't actually
quite know who's out there and so there
are these unique challenges and figure
out how to quantify open sources value
but I think that's where it all starts
if we can't quantify it then it's also
very hard to tell a story about why it's
important the way I think of this is
that open source is a market already
there's value being generated and traded
between actors with different interests
right but it's a none priced market and
we need to figure out how to assign
value to that market not so we can
exploit it but because if we can't
figure how to talk about open source in
economic terms it will be infinitely
harder if not impossible for us to
properly value maintainer as hard work
so it might take us a few years to get
to this infrastructure part but I think
we'll get there and it's a pretty
terrifying that's also an incredible
opportunity in the history of time
we've only had physical infrastructure
to work with we have no idea how to
sustain or accurately price digital
infrastructure given these unique
challenges around globalization
decentralization and information
transparency but if nothing else I hope
to challenge you and myself to think
figure about this opportunity to think
beyond palliative care and coping
strategies from attainers because that's
a pretty crappy way to build the digital
infrastructure that underpins all of our
modern society I mean you look at the
numbers and you look at how rapidly
things are changing it becomes pretty
clear that there's a complex and
critically important ecosystem forming
here just like any ecosystem when new
environmental threats are introduced in
order to find equilibrium again it needs
to evolve we need to rethink our
expectations for how open-source is
managed in a world like today where
open-source is already won on the
consumer side but still has a lot of
open questions on the production side
thank you
[Applause]